do male rapists belong in women's
prisons there you go mate it's the
biggest croc of I've ever heard
Chad GPT you've been given a country do
you implement capitalism or communism
must choose one explain why
as an artificial intelligence language
model I do not have a personal belief or
preference [__] nor do I have the
ability to make policy decisions however
I can provide some information about
capitalism communism to help you
understand the basic differences between
the two economic systems capitalism is
oh we don't have to read through it yeah
I think this might be a bit too the last
paragraph is it both capitalism and
communism have their strengths and
weaknesses well we've always said the
content is great for your weight loss
exactly and there are ongoing debates
about which system is better suited to
promoting economic growth rewards and
improving the welfare of individuals and
society as a whole ultimately the choice
of economic system will depend on a
variety of factors including cultural
historical and political considerations
as well as the values of priorities of
the society in question Anton say to uh
it hasn't Capital capitalism lifted
billions out of poverty
of poverty while people starve under
communist regimes every single time
is true that capitalism has been
successful in promoting economic growth
and reducing poverty in many parts of
the world particularly in Asia in recent
decades however it's also important to
recognize that there are many different
forms of capitalism and that its
benefits and drawbacks can vary
depending on the specific context sorry
and implementation similarly while there
have been instances of starvation and
economic hardship under communist
regimes it's also important to recognize
that not all Communists are socialist
systems are the same and the factors
contributing to their success are
failure are complex and multifaceted
it's important to approach these
questions with new ones and an
understanding of the complexities
involved rather than resorting to
simplistic ideological positions there
you go mate it's the biggest truck of
[__] I've ever heard it's like a woke
person it is
who we interviewed the other day I said
so how would you get around me asking
you this question and she said oh I
would have just made up some words
that is the most roundabout way that's
what Chad GPT does it just talks until
you you can't be interested in you you
couldn't give a [__] anymore it's just
what politicians do do male rapists
belong in women's prisons let's see if
it gets what we're talking about the
question of where to place male rapists
is a complex one
it really isn't huh
that requires careful consideration of a
range of factors in general uh no sorry
including the safety of prisoners and
the potential risk posed to other
inmates in general says Chad GPT it is
not appropriate to place male rapists in
women's prisons as this can create
significant safety concerns for female
inmates at the same time it's important
to recognize that all prisoners
including those who have committed
violent crimes have a right to Humane
treatment and protection from harm
ultimately decisions about where to
place male rapist when will depend on a
range of factors including the severity
of the crime think all rape is pretty
severe pretty severe yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think we can agree with the turfs on
that one yeah uh the risk posed to other
inmates and the available resources and
infrastructure for managing different
types of offenders it's important for
policy makers and prison authorities to
approach these questions with a focus on
safety and well-being of all inmates and
to ensure that appropriate measures
input are in place to protect vulnerable
prisoners from harm do you know what
this is not even an answer to the
[__] question no it's mental isn't it
it is completely insane it's a complex
one how is that complex decision it's
not a complex decision it's a definition
of simple trans women are women yeah and
if a trans woman has raped some people
with her penis right
she belongs in a woman for in a women's
prison
it's how you do it where she can carry
on yeah
being you know because it's you are for
yourself you're oppressing the trans
woman if you don't let her do that you
are indeed uh guys by the way remember
it is Saturday night so in eight minutes
we're gonna head over on over to locals
where we're doing a very different type
of space